I love dancing I'm crazy about it I've
been dancing the passy-muir since I was
six years old my name is Shalini I'm 15
and live in northern Rio de Janeiro
this is my darling brother and my
wonderful little sister and this is my
adopted brother a great guy at the
moment my mother is unemployed that's
actually good for me because I get to
see her more often before there was more
distance between us I'd come home and
she'd be asleep she'd come home and I'd
be asleep
we thrown apart a little it might sound
absurd but I'd like to be a pilot not
many people believe me at first a dancer
going into aviation but my mother wants
me to get a good education and so do I
the wars between the favelas muggings
people who kill other people that's
really awful for everyone a lot of
children here grow up exposed to drug
dealing and become dealers themselves
that's tragic for all Brazilians I think
they could do something better with
their lives this is how you do the
piscina
one two three four one two three four